around five years ago
it struck me that i was losing the
ability to engage with people who aren't
like-minded
the idea of discussing hot button issues
with my fellow americans was starting to
give me more heartburn
than the times that i engaged with
suspected extremists overseas
it was starting to leave me feeling more
embittered and frustrated
and so just like that i shifted my
entire focus from global national
security threats
to trying to understand what was causing
this push
towards extreme polarization at home
as a former cia officer and diplomat who
spent years working on counter-extremism
issues
i started to fear that this was becoming
a far greater threat to our democracy
than any foreign adversary
and so i started digging in and i
started speaking out
which eventually led me to being hired
at facebook and ultimately brought me
here today
to continue warning you about how these
platforms are manipulating and
radicalizing
so many of us and to talk about how to
reclaim our public square
i was a foreign service officer in kenya
just a few years after the september
11th attacks
and i led what some call hearts and
minds campaigns along the somalia border
a big part of my job was to build trust
with communities deemed the most
susceptible to extremist messaging
i spent hours drinking tea with
outspoken anti-western clerics and even
dialogued with some suspected terrorists
and while many of these engagements
began with mutual suspicion
i don't recall any of them resulting in
shouting or insults
and in some cases we even work together
on areas of mutual
interest the most powerful tools we had
were to simply listen learn and build
empathy
this is the essence of hearts and minds
work
because what i found again and again is
that what most people wanted was to feel
heard validated and respected
and i believe that's what most of us
want so what i see happening online
today is especially heartbreaking and a
much harder problem to tackle
we're being manipulated by the current
information ecosystem
and trenching so many of us so far into
absolutism
that compromise has become a dirty word
because right now social media companies
like facebook
profit off of segmenting us and feeding
us personalized content that both
validates and exploits our biases
their bottom line depends on provoking a
strong emotion to keep us engaged
often incentivizing the most
inflammatory and polarizing voices
to the point where finding common ground
no longer feels possible
and despite a growing course of people
crying out for the platforms to change
it's clear they will not do enough on
their own
so governments must define the
responsibility for the real world harms
being caused by these business models
and impose real costs on the damaging
effects they're having to our public
health
our public square and our democracy
but unfortunately this won't happen in
time for the u.s presidential election
so i am continuing to raise this alarm
because even if one day we do have
strong rules in place
it will take all of us to fix this
when i started shifting my focus from
threats abroad to the breakdown in civil
discourse at home
i wondered if we could repurpose some of
these hearts and minds campaigns to help
heal our divides
our more than 200-year experiment with
democracy works
in large part because we are able to
openly and passionately debate our ideas
for the best solutions
but while i still deeply believe in the
power of face-to-face civil discourse
it just cannot compete with the
polarizing effects and scale of social
media right now
the people who are sucked down these
rabbit holes of social media outrage
often feel far harder to break of their
ideological mindsets
than those vulnerable communities i
worked with ever were
so when facebook called me in 2018 and
offered me this role heading its
elections integrity operations for
political advertising
i felt i had to say yes i had no
illusions that i would fix it all but
when
offered the opportunity to help steer
the ship in a better direction i had to
at least try
i didn't work directly on polarization
but i did look at
which issues were the most divisive in
our society and therefore the
most exploitable in elections
interference efforts
which was russia's tactic ahead of 2016.
so i started by asking questions i
wanted to understand the
underlying systemic issues that were
allowing all of this to happen
in order to figure out how to fix it
now i still do believe in the power of
the internet to bring more voices to the
table
but despite their stated goal of
building community
the largest social media companies as
currently constructed
are antithetical to the concept of
reason discourse
there's no way to reward listening to
encourage civil debate and to protect
people who sincerely want to ask
questions
in a business where optimizing
engagement and user growth are the two
most important metrics for success
there's no incentive to help people slow
down
to build in enough friction that people
have to stop
recognize their emotional reaction to
something and question their own
assumptions before engaging
the unfortunate reality is lies are more
engaging online than truth
and salaciousness beats out wonky
fact-based reasoning in a world
optimized for frictionless virality
as long as algorithms goals are to keep
us engaged
they will continue to feed us the poison
that plays to our worst instincts in
human weaknesses
and yes anger mistrust
the culture of fear hatred none of this
is new in america
but in recent years social media has
harnessed all of that and as i see it
dramatically tipped the scales and
facebook
knows it a recent wall street journal
article
exposed an internal facebook
presentation from 2018
that specifically points to the
company's own algorithms for growing
extremist groups presence on their
platform
and for polarizing their users
but keeping us engaged is how they make
their money
the modern information environment is
crystallized around profiling us
and then segmenting us into more and
more narrow categories to perfect this
personalization process
we're then bombarded with information
confirming our views
reinforcing our biases and making us
feel like we belong to something
these are the same tactics we would see
terrorist recruiters using on vulnerable
youth
albeit in smaller more localized ways
before social media
with the ultimate goal of persuading
their behavior
unfortunately i was never empowered by
facebook to have an actual
impact in fact on my second day there my
title and job description were changed
and i was cut out of decision making
meetings
my biggest efforts trying to build plans
to combat disinformation and voter
suppression and political ads were
rejected
and so i lasted just shy of six months
but here is my biggest takeaway from my
time there
there are thousands of people at
facebook who are passionately working on
a product that they truly believe makes
the world a better place
but as long as the company continues to
merely tinker around the margins of
content policy and moderation as opposed
to considering how the entire machine is
designed and monetized
they will never truly address how the
platform is contributing to hatred
division and radicalization
and that's the one conversation i never
heard happen during my time there
because that would require fundamentally
accepting that the thing you built
might not be the best thing for society
and agreeing to alter the entire product
and profit model
so what can we do about this i'm not
saying that social media bears the sole
responsibility for the state that we're
in today
clearly we have deep seated societal
issues that we
need to solve but facebook's response
that it is just a
mirror to society is a convenient
attempt to deflect
any responsibility from the way their
platform
is amplifying harmful content and
pushing some users towards extreme views
and facebook could if they wanted to fix
some of this
they could stop amplifying and
recommending the conspiracy theorists
the hate groups
the purveyors of disinformation and yes
in some cases
even our president they could stop using
the same personalization techniques
to deliver political rhetoric that they
used to sell as sneakers
they could retrain their algorithms to
focus on a metric other than engagement
and they could build in guard rails to
stop certain content from going viral
before
being reviewed and they could do all of
this
without becoming what they call the
arbiters of truth
but they made it clear that they will
not go far enough to do the right thing
without being forced to
and to be frank why should they the
markets keep rewarding them and they're
not breaking the law
because as it stands there are no u.s
laws compelling facebook or any social
media company
to protect our public square our
democracy and
even our elections we have seated the
decision making on what rules to write
and what to enforce to the ceos of
for-profit
internet companies is this what we want
a post-truth world where toxicity and
tribalism trump bridge building and
consensus-seeking
i do remain optimistic that we still
have more in common with each other than
the current
media and online environment portray and
i
do believe that having more perspective
surface makes for a more robust and
inclusive democracy
but not the way it's happening right now
and it bears emphasizing
i do not want to kill off these
companies i
just want them held to a certain level
of accountability just like the rest of
society
it is time for our governments to step
up and do
their jobs of protecting our citizenry
and while there isn't
one magical piece of legislation that
will fix this all
i do believe that governments can and
must
find the balance between protecting free
speech
and holding these platforms accountable
for their effects on society
and they could do so in part by
insisting on actual transparency around
how these recommendation engines are
working
around how the curation amplification
and targeting
are happening you see i want these
companies held accountable
not for if an individual posts
misinformation or extreme rhetoric
but for how their recommendation engines
spread it
how their algorithms are steering people
towards it
and how their tools are used to target
people with it
i tried to make change from within
facebook and failed
and so i've been using my voice again
for the past few years to continue
sounding this alarm and hopefully
inspire more people to demand this
accountability
my message to you is simple pressure
your government representatives to step
up and stop seating our public square to
for-profit interests
help educate your friends and family
about how they're being manipulated
online
push yourselves to engage with people
who aren't like-minded
make this issue a priority we need a
whole of society approach to fix this
and my message to the leaders of my
former employer facebook
is this right now
people are using your tools exactly as
they were designed
to sow hatred division and distrust and
you're not just allowing it
you are enabling it and yes there are
lots of great stories of positive things
happening on your platform
around the globe but that doesn't make
any of this
okay and it's only getting worse as
we're heading into our election and even
more concerning
face our biggest potential crisis yet if
the results aren't trusted
and if violence breaks out so when in
2021 you once again say
we know we have to do better i want you
to remember this moment
because it's no longer just a few
outlier voices
civil rights leaders academics
journalists
advertisers your own employees are
shouting from the rooftops
that your policies and your business
practices are harming people
and democracy you own your decisions
but you can no longer say that you
couldn't have seen it coming
thank you